hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game that was played in the
2008
chess olympiad in dresden and it's a
game between finnish grandmaster
uh tomi neibuck and uh of course uh
world champion magnus crawls and he was
not a world champion
in those days but he was still
incredibly strong and even
uh here he's i think some 17 years old
he was rated almost
2 800. so quite a monster already
and this game was sent to me by a
subscriber mikhail civil noinan
and he also uh said a lot of things
about the game he also
shared a video with me regarding this
game which is also in the description
below
first thing you will see if you want to
check that out this game it's a very
short part of the vid
part of the game but you can check it
out if you want it features uh moment in
this game that we are going to cover
uh but uh that being said uh let's check
out this game as it's
just uh just wonderful and uh uh
finland was losing uh the match to
norway and uh
naiba needed a victory here against
magnus and also
uh on the other board they also needed a
win so let's see let's see what happened
here
so naive with the white pieces opened
with knight to f3 he went for the
reity opening and magnus replied with
knight to f6 we have c4
uh e6 knight to c3 and now
d5 striking in the center uh we have d4
so transposing from english to the
queen's gambit declined
and now bishop to e7 black is ready to
castle we have bishop to f4 by naibak
uh and now magnus castles we have e3 now
preparing to develop the light square
bishop and
knight b to d7 so this is all very
standard stuff the the harvest
harvest defense of the queen's gambit
declined and here
c5 by white this uh seemingly
anti-positional move is basically the
strongest move in the position
uh because nowadays uh the word
anti-positional in chess
means that the engines say it's the best
move so we can no longer say such things
as a
anti-positional uh if the engines say
it's okay it it's
it's okay and here it is still
considered the best move so c5
and black will now try to undermine this
pawn with moves like b6
and if defender would be 4 then a5 which
is something that is
seen very often when white grabs more
space like this on the queen side with
c5
so c6 first and now bishop to d3 white
continues development is ready to castle
and now b6 we start we start undermining
the pawn
as the white is no longer fighting for
the for the center here and we want to
well we want to just capture here and
then after characters win the pawn so
white defends this with b4
and the magnus further tries to
undermine the pawn structure with
a5 and here we have a3 again just
defending the pawn structure
and now bishop to a6 and interestingly
uh some uh some uh when was that in 2014
in the uh rematch in the world chess
championship
match between carlson and anand where
carlson was defending the title
uh this position also occurred and in
that uh position
anand captured the bishop on a6 and won
the game against magnus but here
uh we have just uh castles uh in this
position
but the position has been reached many
times aside from this game also like i
said was played in the game
uh anand versus carlson in 2014 it was
played in the moment
versus arunian arunian also had this
position against adams
uh gerichu had it against nakamura
kramnik had it against wang hao so
it's a position that occurred quite a
lot uh in top tier games and uh
in those lower uh rated um as well
so here like i said we have castles and
now queen to c8
uh we have queen to c2 uh white
continues development connects to the
rooks now also puts pressure on that h7
pawn uh so here black captures with
bishop captures queen captures and now
magnus played this knight to h5 move
uh and it is only as of this position uh
from move 13 that the disposition has
never been reached again
so let's see how uh how naibak deals
with this he goes bishop to e5
which makes sense uh because it also
comes with a trick
uh so what do you play here uh if you go
for this knight captures and knight
captures then this knight is just a
monster
and there's no really there's really no
good way to get rid of it and it kind of
seems like you can play f6 but by
playing f6 you actually
uh block your own knight from coming
back into the game so here white can
just grab a pawn
knight captures and after queen captures
g for win the knight you won a pawn
and okay you weaken your king's position
a little bit but it's not like you're
you're under attack or anything this is
perfectly fine for white
so bishop to e5 uh somewhat a tricky
move so magnus just continues developing
he plays queen to b7
and now rook f the c1 as the
uh c file might open up so we want to
have the rook ready here to
put some pressure along the c file black
does the same rook after c8
and now h3 also freeing the h2 square
for the for the bishop uh if
uh if it will be needed so here
magnus finally eliminates this bishop we
have knight capture sunny five
knight captures on e5 and now magnus
closed the
closes the position with b5 and now he
probably wants to capture
on b4 maybe trade off the rooks here
along the a file trade
the other rook as well and so on so here
we have rook c
the b1 uh and here magnus played
queen to c7 uh here you could also go
for characters and characters
and then for example rook capture sun a1
will capture sun a1
uh but the problem is after rook to a8
you would get
rook captures on a8 queen capture 78 and
now this knight captures on b5 that's
the problem if
you just continue with this seemingly
good plan the problem is this
uh uh peace sacrifice captures and
captures and then white gets two
connected past pawns
for a knight which is a sacrifice that
often occurs when white goes for this
c5 uh structure which is incredibly
difficult to defend off for black as you
see
so after rook c to b1 magnus goes queen
to c7
instead but now the position is actually
uh well if not winning it's
incredibly close to winning but it
should be winning so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find
the absolute best move for white while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
spotting the move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's a4 put additional pressure on this
b5 pawn and now you will see that black
has
very little replies so of course this is
the threat
there's a triple attack on this pawn
here and if you go for something like b
captures on a4 then you get rook
captures on a4 if a captures then rook a
captures and it seems like you've traded
off everything
but white's position is incredible here
he has rooks doubled on the b
file he can go rook to rook to b7 he can
go rook to b6 put pressure on this pawn
and this is just an overwhelming
position for white and uh
of course you cannot trade off the rooks
along the b file because here white just
trades captures captures captures and
captures and you are
losing the c6 pawn this comes with with
an attack on the bishop and the queen
so here it's just captures captures and
now this uh well past c pawn is just
going to win the game easily so instead
after a4 magnus tried the other
uh the other capture he played the he
played eight captures on b4
uh but now comes a captures on b5 and
here we have a beautiful beautiful
piece sacrifice and you don't really
have a good reply here
uh you you kind of have to capture the
knight or otherwise it's not gonna
um yeah you haven't really gained
anything you
if you just wait white will play b6 and
get a get a beautiful pass pawn
and if you go for something like
captures here and try to completely
ignore this then you can either just uh
first trade on a8 or you can go knight
captures and b5 doesn't really matter
after b
after queen to b7 you're going to play
rook captures on a8 and after rook
captures you're going to play rook
captures on b4 and it's pretty much the
same
you get another amazing pass pawn here
and it's
uh well it's uh if not the winning it's
incredibly close to winning but
in a practical game uh black black
definitely
will not be able to hold this so instead
after eight captures on b5 magnus
accepted the challenge he played b
captures on c3 he grabbed the piece with
the idea of giving back the piece very
quickly with bishop captures on c5 so
here we have
knight captures on c6 b6 is also an idea
just uh
creating a pass pawn but why not first
eliminate the c6 pawn and now you have
two connected pass pawns which is
uh you know two connected past pawns so
ready to go on the sixth rank
definitely worth a worth a piece so
knight back to f6 and magnus tries to
activate
this knight and now queen captures on c3
we have bishop back to f8
uh so white never has this uh capture to
come with check then you can start
pushing those past pawns
and here we just have rook captures on
a8
rook captures and rook to a1 now trying
to trade off
uh all of the uh remaining rooks if
captures and captures then is it just
too easy to play this would white you're
just going to bring the queen up the
board and start pushing that pass pawn
to victory
so instead magnus goes for something
else he plays knight to e4 he puts
pressure on the queen and now
the queen still has to remain defending
uh the rook on a1 so queen to b2
uh keeping an eye on that rook on a1 and
now
magnus uh moves the rook away from the a
file he simply cannot
uh afford a trade here he goes back rook
to e8
and now comes knight to e5 and now the
knight has
moved away from the from the past pawn
now you can start pushing those pawns
and here knight captures on c5 this was
uh this was magnus's plan when he played
the this setup with with the knight here
he wants to
give back uh a piece and grab two points
while he's at it but now
uh once again uh feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move for white
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not grabbing the knight right away and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show yes it is b6 and this
is uh this is incredibly important
because now
uh the queen uh has to go somewhere and
where do you
where do you put the queen in the game
queen to b7 was played but there really
aren't any better squares
because now uh what white plays is not
d captures on c5 but rather queen to b5
because the rook on e8 is undefended
that was the whole point and now when
the rook moves you are you are going to
capture on c5 and then you will again
have two connected past pawns and the
queen will be guarding this pawn so the
bishop cannot recapture so that's that's
the stuff
so here rook to a8 not threatening to
capture the rook on a1
but nyback just trades here with
captures captures
and now d captures on c5
uh so sorry uh captures captures and uh
now uh d captures on c5 uh we have queen
the a1
with check king to h2 and now magnus
wins
back uh this knight so queen captures on
e5 with
check so magnus is now up a piece but
those two connected pass pawns are just
just incredible
and so we are already on 31 but i just
wanted to mention uh at that moment um
at that moment where b6 was played uh
this is the moment
that you can check there's a two-minute
footage in the description below first
thing uh
you will see so you can check out at
this moment uh
as uh it was uh very interesting to see
how carson reacted to this and you can
see
uh through his body language that he did
not uh
he wasn't really happy when he saw this
b6 move on the board but getting back to
our game
uh after this queen to a1 check move
king to h2 like we said queen
uh grabs the knight with check and now
g3
and now magnus needs to play something
but it's unclear what those pawns are
just gonna march forward and you're
gonna
have multiple queens to deal with so
here one idea is h5 h4 maybe try to bust
open the position here magnus tries it a
different way he plays d4
and wants to bust open the position here
but just b7
white doesn't react to this and he says
this is just winning
so queen to f5 trying to get some sort
of a perpetual here with queen captures
on f2
uh but um nyback just goes back queen to
b2 defends the pawn
we have captures on e3 by magnus f
captures on e3
and now queen captures on c5 there was
nothing better
now naiba brings a second queen into the
game and now the game can easily be
resigned
magnus played queen captures on e3 and
now
just queen to c7 consolidating with h6
by magnus
getting rid of some back rank weaknesses
and now
uh we have queen beat the c2 we have
queen to d4
and now we have queen seven to c4
offering a queen trade and it was in
this position i know 39
that magnus carlsen uh resigned the game
and tommy neibach uh
played this remarkable remarkable game
where he defeated uh in almost uh 2800
uh
raided magnus carlsen and it was it was
a pretty good deal uh for finland as
the final score between uh finland and
norway
in this 2008 address then olympiad uh
ended
2-2 so it was a draw so real really
really awesome stuff and um as
my subscribers suggested when he emailed
me uh tommy neibach as he
he is the finnish grandmaster and he's
an incredibly strong grandmaster
but it doesn't appear that he's uh
playing chess any longer he
he has a positive score against magnus
carlsen but i i don't think he has any
games played after
2019 uh i think he shifted to poker
and i i wasn't really able to find any
more info but it seems that
uh he completely shifted his attention
towards poker uh
i apologize if i'm wrong but it does
appear to be so
uh but yeah this uh remarkable game
remains and i'm
very happy that uh you've sent it to me
so uh there you have it uh
always important to use that hashtag
suggestion uh because even if i don't
see it now i will always go to my
channel then i'll write a
hashtag suggestion in the search bar
also i'm using hashtag suggestion on my
emails on
uh wherever i can so keep using it and
we will
always be able to find nice games like
this one
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i don't know if i mentioned
this but
um uh mikhail also chose the title of
this uh video carlson's finished
nightmare so
i hope you enjoyed that as well i would
like to thank john austin
eric berman edmund freeman niels gordon
and narendra adala for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day